welcome to the Google cloud platform
education series my name is Jeff Davis
and in this session we'll discuss
creating best-in-class storage solutions
with Google Cloud storage we'll be doing
a moderated Q&A throughout the session
so feel free to present your questions
in the ask your question here field
let's get started so this is our agenda
for the session we're going to begin
with a series of demos these are gonna
highlight the most typical use cases and
just how easy it is to set up
high-performing really functional
solutions on top of Google Cloud Storage
out of the demos we'll move into a
discussion of the overall GCS feature
set and how it might apply to challenges
that you're tackling within your
organization we'll take a few minutes to
talk about the best ways to find
information after this session if you
have questions and we'll also talk about
how to evaluate GCS for specific use
cases specific problems that you're
trying to solve and again throughout the
session feel free to submit your
questions so on to the demos the first
use case that is very typical with GCS
is using it as a target for off-site
backups so I'm gonna bring up a piece of
backup software this is a product called
retrospect there are lots of different
products in this class
Veritas for instance is a partner with
Google and has their net backup solution
lots of solutions will actually take
your on-site backup data and pump it
into the cloud where you have then an
off-site backup and it can be stored
large amounts of data for very small
amounts of dollars so what we're gonna
do is we're going to start by
configuring the products so that it will
use Google Cloud Storage as its target
location so I'm going to create a media
set and you'll notice that I have a
variety of options I'm going to choose
to send it to the cloud we're gonna call
this demo backup set and we'll go ahead
and encrypt it and give it a simple
password
now at this point I'm prompted for what
back-end cloud service I want to use and
I need to use a configuration string
provided to me by Google so that is
storage API is GCP webinar backups and
then I need an access key and a secret
key and this is easily configured within
the Google Cloud storage user interface
so I'm gonna actually go to Google Cloud
Storage this is my project I've got a
set of buckets you'll notice my GCP
webinar backups bucket is here I'm going
to click on settings interoperability
and you'll notice that I already have
some keys created so I'm gonna actually
use one of these keys so I need the
access key and that's going to go here
and then I need the secret key and
that's gonna go here it uses SSL to
transfer the data so it's encrypted in
flight and now I have my backup set now
I'm gonna actually do a backup
retrospect can backup an individual
machine which is what I'm gonna do here
you can backup all the workstations on a
network or it can backup multiple
servers on a network so this could be
backups of your internal servers that
are application servers or file servers
as well as backups of all of your
important work station data so I'm using
this simply because it's easy to install
and it's relatively quick to demonstrate
so I'm going to select what I want to
backup and I don't want to backup my
entire hard drive because we'll be here
too long instead what I want to do is I
wanted to pick a videos folder I'm gonna
back that folder up and I'm going to
back it up to the cloud notice it's a
cloud demo backup set and I'm gonna run
it now it takes a little while for this
backup job to execute so I'm gonna go
ahead and let that run in the background
while we move on to the next part of the
demo
let's take a look at performance one of
the things that you care about not only
is storing large amounts of data
inexpensively but you want to make sure
that your access to that data is fast
and is also reliable so again if I go to
sorry if I go to my bucket browser for
this project you'll notice that I've got
a variety of buckets other than my
backups bucket so I have a regional
bucket in the west of the United States
I have a multi regional bucket and then
I have a Nearline bucket and a cold line
bucket and these are four different
storage classes and I'm going to show
you how performance looks for each one
of these and then we'll talk about the
differences in a little bit so in order
to test performance across a variety of
areas I've actually created a bunch of
test instances so you'll notice that
I've got virtual machines running in
different parts of the world so I've got
one in Asia I've got one on the East
Coast which is not in the same region as
my regional bucket I've got one on the
west coast which is in the same region
as my regional bucket and I've got one
in Europe so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to SSH into each of these virtual
machines so that I can generate load
against GCS okay so let me shrink that
window down notice my backup is still
running in the background so I'm going
to shrink that down as well and what I
have here is four SSH windows one to
each of my different machines so I'm
gonna use a curl command curl is a
command that basically is going to do a
URL request the items that I'm pulling
out of the buckets have actually been
made publicly accessible and can be
accessed using a standard URL so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to copy
down a relatively big file from a
regional bucket so this bucket is stored
in the West Coast and what we really
want to see is is it fast man can I pull
down big files really quickly so I'm
gonna go ahead and enter
this command in each of the windows and
what this should do is start a file
download from four different instances
in four different regions and what we
want to see is what does the performance
look like okay so if I look at the
instance in the West you can see I'm
averaging 292 megabytes per second
download that's pretty quick if I look
in the eastern United States
it's about 314 megabytes so roughly the
same performance if I look in amia its
203 megabytes and this is because the
client that's running in Europe is
accessing resources stored in a Western
Region bucket that means that it is not
connected with the same high throughput
low latency low latency connections that
say this instance in the West Coast is
so relatively quick we averaged it looks
like 96 megabytes per second in Europe
we knit MANET we averaged 85 megabytes
per second and the East Coast we managed
about 100 megabytes per second and in
Asia about 92 so pretty good performance
around the globe from data that's stored
in the western part of the United States
I'm gonna do the same thing except I'm
going to copy this not from my western
regional bucket but instead from a multi
regional bucket so a multi regional
bucket is a bucket where your data is
actually replicated not just in the
western United States but in the central
and in the eastern United States as well
what this means is that it's going to be
closer to a wider range of clients so
again I'm going to copy this and we're
going to start it in Asia and then we're
gonna go to Europe and then we're gonna
go to the western United States and
there was one more in there there's the
East you can see that the multi-regional
bucket is even faster right so again
we're at roughly a gigabyte per second
in the West in amia we're at about 500
megabytes in the eastward about a
gigabyte and in asia-pacific we're at
about four hundred thirteen so
in multi-regional buckets even faster
than the regional buckets now I'm going
to do a small file from the
multi-regional buckets and this is
important for the next test which is the
near line test so what I want to do is I
want to see if you download this small
file how fast is it and again super fast
super fast super fast super fast
okay now Nearline as you may know
Nearline is a less expensive storage
class that's intended for data that
isn't accessed that frequently so you
put they move it a little bit further
away from the standard access points
means that you can access it but it is
going to cost you every time you read it
we'll talk about the pricing in just a
second but what I want to show you here
is even though you've moved it to a
tiered storage offering it doesn't
actually slow down the the speed with
which you can access or download the
files so here we go you'll notice from
Nearline I'm still seeing six hundred
and fifty two megabytes I'm seeing four
hundred forty megabytes I'm seeing seven
hundred and sixty-one megabytes I'm
seeing three hundred and eighty
megabytes
notice you had like access time was tens
or hundreds of milliseconds it was
really quick and it was the same command
to access it from near line as from a
regional or multi regional bucket now
let's go a step further let's go to cold
line so cold line is even less expensive
it's intended for data that you only
access very infrequently but again use
the same access mechanisms and you get
the same retrieval speeds as you do from
standard buckets so you'll notice 413
778 511 929 so even though you've moved
to tiered storage and you've gone from
regional to near line two cold line
storage you haven't had to sacrifice
initial access time or download
throughput or change the API is that use
this is a big plus relative to some
other solutions that are available to
you in the meantime let me go back
and check the backup software you can
see that the backup is actually running
we'll take a look when it's done to see
that it's actually stored the stuff in
the bucket so we've got backup running
we've just showed performance and the
relative performance of a multi regional
bucket versus a regional bucket versus
near line versus cold line so now let's
take a look at a couple other things
that you can do
so one frequent use of Google Cloud
Storage is to store large media objects
for serving on websites so here we have
an example learning management system
that's got videos embedded in there
micro learning lessons and you can see
this module is all about the fact that
mantas are awesome this is a video that
I took while diving with manta is off of
Kona if I load this page you can see
that it actually is streaming the video
to my machine now this video is stored
in Google Cloud storage and in fact if
we go to the cloud storage UI what you
can see is here is a bucket for that
project and this bucket has got a couple
of copies of the mantas streaming video
file it has a bunch of other ones as
well so what happens is you set up your
webserver and it simply proxies these
media files you can see that these files
are shared publicly and there's a public
link option if you click on the public
link this actually gives you our URL and
you can serve the video directly from
GCS so there's me talking about
something else okay so this is a very
common application and it's super super
easy you just upload your files you
click on share publicly and you get a
link that you can then publish within
your web pages so let me close those two
windows I'm going to check out my backup
and see how we're doing it's still
thinking about it
okay so I'm going to let that continue
to bake in the background it's going to
go into the webinar backups bucket and
you can see that there
is a demo backup set and this is where
the backup is occurring it's not done
yet but it's backing stuff up okay let's
look at another application so GCS is a
really good place to stage data that you
are moving into or out of data analytics
jobs so here's an example of a big
analytics table that I use for a
customer success application that I've
built so you can see that this is a big
query table it has it's not that big
right it has five hundred twenty-five
thousand role rows
there are obviously much bigger ones if
you look at the bigquery samples you can
go to the Wikipedia benchmark and you'll
see that they've got 1 million rows 1
billion rows 100 billion rows so that
makes my little data set look paltry
actually but five hundred twenty-five
thousand rows is would be a lot to write
row by row so instead what we want to do
is we actually want to import this data
and the easiest way to import it is you
upload it to GCS and then GCS has a
really easy integration with bigquery so
if you look here's a bucket this is the
bucket associated with the success HQ
software that's the customer success
platform and you can see that we have
it's not again it's not a huge file but
it's a 45 48 megabyte file and this has
got the five hundred and twenty five
thousand rows so this could be you know
think of it as being 500 million rows
again you just upload it to the bucket
and then in bigquery if you want to
import it you simply say I want to
create a new table and you say I want to
choose a file actually I don't want a
file upload I want to do Google Cloud
storage okay and then you need the path
to the file so that's going to be indeed
let's see yes
GS colon slash slash shq transfer slash
and then the name of the file is this
and then I could specify the schema
explicitly I'm gonna actually have
bigquery trying to automatically detect
it and I'm gonna give it a demo events
table name and create a table and this
then inserts a job and it's gonna import
the CSV file from Google Cloud storage
it'll take if I'm not lying about five
more seconds and it should be done
you'll notice here we've got the entry
showing that the demo events table is
loading oh there we go we're done
so you'll notice it's created fields for
each one in details you can see that
we've imported five hundred and twenty
two thousand some odd rows and if I want
to see that this data is in fact live
what I can do is I can see strength this
down a little bit pick this and I'm
going to do select star from events dot
demo events table
so let's run the query and if all goes
well we should see I get all of the
event data that's recorded by my
customer success system and I have five
hundred twenty two thousand rows so
again that took about ten to fifteen
seconds if you extrapolate that so if
you go to five hundred million it's
still a relatively quick import and
again this is using GCS as a staging
mechanism for getting data into bigquery
or into data flow or into data proc it's
also a great target repository for GCP
services so any of those big data
analytics tools can actually dump the
data into Google Cloud storage and then
you can actually share this with other
folks let's switch back to my backup and
it looks like my backup is actually
complete so if I go to the backup bucket
I should now have a full demo backup set
and this was about a gigabyte of data so
you can see there's a 600 Meg file on a
420 Meg file I had about a gigabyte
worth of videos that I uploaded
relatively quickly so what we've got
here is examples of a variety of
different applications we have files
that are just stored for download this
might be appropriate for instance if
your software company and you're
distributing your application you want
to make sure people can download the
application and that it's highly
available and a good download
performance we did backups where we took
large amounts in this case only a
gigabyte but again if you did this
across a bunch of machines you would
take all of that data and you would pump
it up to the cloud and then you could
actually store these backups in various
tiers of storage so old backups you
could have in cold line and so forth and
we talked about serving media and web
applications and we talked about using
GCS as a staging area for getting data
in and out of big data analytics
pipelines hopefully you've seen at least
one or two things here that really gets
you excited and curious as to how you
can leverage GCS for your company
so let's switch back to the presentation
and let's talk at a high level about the
wide range of capabilities and the
pricing information about cloud storage
so again cloud storage is a unified
storage product that runs a top of
Google's massive storage and networking
infrastructure it is blob storage or
binary large object storage this is not
a regular file system where you're
reading and writing and updating data
within files this is where you store
lots of files that are relatively static
and you read them periodically for
analysis or you just keep them in
archival and they feed into things like
live data serving or analytics that sort
of stuff
you have one consistent API to access
all of the different types of storage
you have similar latency and download
speeds across those classes which makes
it super easy to work with so here's a
slide that we're gonna spend a little
time on this details the four different
storage classes and their differences
within Google Cloud Storage so the one
that most people start with is regional
storage and remember in Google cloud
platform a region is a collection of
resources that are interconnected with
high throughput low latency network
connections that means that an instance
in the West Region can read and write
data to a GCS bucket in the West region
very very quickly your data when you
write it into Google Cloud Storage is
actually replicated across machines
throughout the region what this means is
you have very very high durability and
very high availability the likelihood
that you are gonna lose data is
extremely low because even if a
particular storage device drops out your
data is replicated even if a zone goes
out your data is replicated across other
zones within the region your data is
also highly available which means it
again
goes down you'll have live copies of
your data in another zone within the
same region and you can access it there
then people sort of moved to
multi-regional multi-regional is where
you have resources that are holding your
data and they're not just spread out
within a region they're actually spread
out through what's called a multi
regional area so there are three multi
regional areas in Google cloud platform
there's a North American or a US region
there's an Emir region and an
asia-pacific region so this gives you
even higher levels of availability if
the western region goes down you can
still read your data from the central or
the eastern region so you can see
actually that the availability is better
with multi regional as opposed to
regional you also get a performance
improvement in that because your data is
in multiple locations throughout the
United States it's more likely that any
given user will be closer to that data
on the right hand side then you have
near line and cold line storage and
these are intended to hold data at
reduced costs but it's data that you
don't access as often so basically what
happens is if you put something in near
line Google essentially puts it
someplace that it's less expensive for
Google to store but it's more expensive
for Google to serve so what they do is
they cut the price for storage but then
they make you pay for accessing it you
don't pay a performance penalty you
still have access times in tens of
milliseconds and you still have high
throughput but they have to go through
more contortions to serve the data at
that speed therefore while it cost less
to store it actually cost more to access
so it's really good if you access this
data infrequently so at the top here we
so this is intended for data that is
frequently accessed across regions with
inner region access less than once a
month or access less than once a year
durability is a lot of nines
availability the worst case scenario is
1% of the time you might not be able to
access your near line or cold line data
at a given point
in time and it's three 9s for regional
and it's three nines and a 5/4
multi-regional you use the same api's or
the same GUI or the same command-line
utilities for getting data in and out of
all of these storage classes you have
the same latency for reads the
difference here is on cost so at the top
end the top shelf multi-regional storage
class you pay 2.6 cents per gigabyte per
month for regional you get a discount
you pay 2 cents per gigabyte per month
Nearline you pay half that you pay one
cent per gigabyte per month what's
interesting though is you pay roughly 1
cent per gigabyte to read the data off
the disk so if you read the data once a
month to you about breakeven if you read
the data once every three months you're
clearly gonna come out ahead vs.
regional if you read the data three
times a month you would actually pay
more for Nearline than you did for
regional and then cold line you pay
seven tenths of a cent per gigabyte per
month but you pay a higher access charge
now storage when it comes to the cost
entailed in Google Cloud Storage you
paid this ongoing storage fee then for
an airline and cold line you pay to
access or read the data off the disk and
then you also pay for what's called
Network egress so that is any data that
leaves the region where the data is
stored you end up having to pay and it
starts at about the lowest price is
about 8 cents per terabyte transfer now
again if you're using a regional bucket
and your server is in the West Region
and it's reading and writing to a cloud
bucket that's in the West Region it
never leaves the West Region data
centers therefore you don't pay network
egress but for instance with that
learning management system with a little
video lesson I'm paying 20 cents per or
I'm sorry 2 cents per gigabyte per month
to store it and then every time somebody
loads that page the data is leaving the
data center and so I'm having to pay
you know between eight and eleven cents
per terabyte of storage transferred out
of the data center
all in all far less expensive than
building the same type of infrastructure
on-premise also far more secure far more
reliable speaking of security you can
rely on not only Google's hardware
infrastructure but on their software and
processes to secure your data so Google
has invested huge amounts of money
developing processes technical talent
and software that keeps its data secure
so they run at least a half dozen
applications that have a billion active
users those need to be secure and
they're basically leasing you space on
their infrastructure so for instance all
your data is encrypted Google
automatically encrypts the data they
hold the encryption keys and rotate
those encryption keys on a
well-documented basis if you work in an
industry where you have to manage the
keys you can use GCS with customer
supplied encryption keys I am is
identity and access management this is a
mechanism that you use to control who
can do what to which resources in your
GCS projects and the same permissioning
scheme and authentication system that
you use to manage access to compute
engine instances or to bigquery tables
you can use to control access to buckets
and objects within your project in
addition to that so for instance editors
on your project can read and write to
all of your buckets by default but let's
say you have a particular bucket that
you don't want every editor on your
project to have access to only a very
few particular people should have access
you have an additional layer of security
which is access control lists and those
access control lists can be set at the
bucket level and you can have default
permissions set for every object inside
or you can manually and explicitly set
access control lists on individual
objects in some cases you want to make
access to objects within a bucket
available to people who don't have
Google
so one thing about iam is it requires
the person to whom you're granting roles
to have a Google account in a lot of
cases you are serving up media and you
may want to serve that to the public in
which case you said a special Apple that
says it's available to everyone but in
other cases you don't want it to be
publicly available you want to secure it
for particular individuals but you can't
guarantee that those individuals have
Google accounts so there are code
libraries available for developers to
create what are called signed URLs and
these URLs basically have an indication
of what a person can do to a given
resource in GCS how long that permission
is granted and then anybody who holds
that URL can actually access without
having a Google account so this is not
unlike those password reset verification
emails where it goes to your email and
it gives you a big long arbitrary link
and if you click on that then you can
reset your password and having that link
is your permission to reset your
password and it's only good for a
certain period of time this is similar
in concept and for those of you who
develop mobile applications using the
firebase mobile development framework
firebase actually has their own storage
security rule system which makes it
really easy for developers to create
security rules without having to worry
about the particulars of GCS and they
apply directly to GCS on your behalf
ways to get data in to Google Cloud
storage
so there are simple ways they're
interactive ways so you can go through
the GUI and click a button and upload a
file you can use the gsutil utility to
copy a file from your local machine but
obviously if you're doing large
quantities of files or maybe really you
know ten hundred terabyte files doing
sort of an interactive session from your
local machine probably doesn't make a
lot of sense other ways to get data in
include integrations with other GCP
services so for instance I showed you
the bigquery integration you can just as
easily dump a huge bigquery table or the
results of a big data product process
you can dump that all out in
to google cloud storage very easily
there are third-party integrations and
the retrospect software that I showed
you was an example of that that is
third-party backup software that writes
data directly into the cloud for really
large volumes of data you might go with
a third-party service or a third-party
appliance so companies like sedara
basically create appliances that they
put on Prem and they act as bridges
where they pull huge amounts of on-prem
data and they pump them through very
high speed network connections up into
the cloud and then third party services
would be something like Iron Mountain
who will actually come to you pick up a
bunch of your media take it off-site and
upload it to the cloud for you getting
data out sort of the reverse process so
again you can do it interactively so you
can just click on a link and download a
file you can use gsutil to copy files
out of the cloud onto an on-prem device
again data can go out of GCS into other
Google cloud platform services very
easily we showed that with bigquery the
LMS system that I showed you where you
had that little video module about
mantas that's using proxy web access so
basically you hit a web server and the
web server when it sees a URL pointing
to a Google Cloud storage URL it will
proxy it'll grab the data out of GCS and
then serve it up or you can even serve
files directly out of GCS so I showed
you where the public links are if you
click on that link
GCS actually acts as a web server so you
can upload a bunch of static files and
run a web server out of GCS without any
additional software to manage your data
I've already highlighted highlighted
this a couple of times you have a
consistent set of api's that you can use
across all the storage classes there are
also some really cool features that make
it easier to keep just the right amount
of data in just the right versions of
data so for instance there's lifecycle
management what this allows you to do is
say hey any files that are older than
365 days I want to move them into
Nearline from regional so I actually
want to move them into a different
storage class and therefore I get to
save money or I
want to only keep the latest three
versions of a particular file and throw
away anything older than that
so you set these as little JSON snippets
they describe what a particular bucket
or object does in terms of lifecycle
management and then the system takes
care of it for you
speaking of versioning there is an
object versioning within GCS and what
this allows you to do is basically say
when you overwrite an existing object
with a new object it keeps the previous
version and so you can override it over
and over and over again and have lots of
different versions of the same object
and then at any time you can list those
versions and you can actually recover a
version that has been previously stored
now obviously you have to pay for all
these multiple versions so that stacks
up and that's why you combine it with
lifecycle management to maybe age out
and only keep the last three versions an
object change notification is a feature
where by you can have a bucket notify an
external application every time a new
object gets dropped into the bucket for
instance so let's say you had an
application where users uploaded photos
and every time a photo got uploaded you
wanted to actually create a thumbnail so
you wanted a service to open the image
shrink it down and save the thumbnail in
a database for instance what you would
do is you would configure object change
notification on the bucket every time a
new file gets uploaded a web hook fires
talks to your server application that
then responds by creating the thumbnail
okay so given all these capabilities you
want to start thinking about where could
we leverage cloud storage to solve
problems for our business one example
here is the Autism Speaks project
so what Autism Speaks wanted to do was
create a really large shared dataset
about genomic information related to
autism so every sequenced genome takes
up to 200 gigabytes of data they started
by sequencing roughly 1,300 genomes so
this created over a hundred terabytes of
data now 100 terabytes of data doesn't
seem that large but remember the car
it wasn't just these 1300 they wanted to
have 10,000 plus people who had their
genomes sequenced and now you're talking
multiple petabytes of data that's a
significant amount of data where can you
store this data so that you can control
who has access to it you can host it
relatively inexpensively and it has high
performance downloads around the world
well they did it on Google cloud
platform using GCS so they ended up
creating this data set that could be
used by the best scientists in the world
to run analyses against trillions of
data points to try to find new ways of
addressing autism in individuals you may
not have something quite this big or you
may have something actually bigger in
any case GCS probably will work really
well for you now after this session if
you come up with questions and you want
to learn more about cloud storage where
do you look search is your friend if you
search on Google Cloud storage and then
whatever topic you're interested in it's
very likely that the first link is going
to be what you want so for example here
we've searched on Google Cloud Storage
classes and what we get is a link to the
article that has all the information
that fed the table that we looked at
earlier if you're trying to figure out
the right command line structure for
doing things using the Jewess GS util
utility type in gsutil and then the
action that you want to perform so like
gsutil copy or gsutil move or gsutil
rename again like every other GCP
project the Google Cloud Storage
documentation at the top level has got
this nice six sections it's got a
QuickStart it's got a series of how-to
guides such as how to create buckets how
to upload or download files how to
create signed URLs that has deep dives
into the api's and general concepts it
has tutorials and other resources
including pricing information and link
to a pricing calculator which you can
use to sort of predict what your costs
will be some things to consider as
you're evaluating applying Google Cloud
storage two particular use cases in your
organization again have a process and be
methodical it's not hard but do a good
job of it figure out what it is that you
need to know in order to determine if
GCS is appropriate for the use cases
you're thinking about figure out what
you need to test and what your sort of
acceptance threshold is so for instance
we need to know that we get X kind of
performance in Australia or we need to
know that we can keep our monthly budget
below a certain level then figure out
how you're going to do to testing so you
need to figure out how many buckets how
many objects how much data
what kind of integrations you're going
to use with third party products and so
forth and do a little bit of research to
figure out how you're going to implement
it and then figure out who's gonna
participate somebody probably is gonna
architect the solution somebody is going
to be responsible for setting it up and
operating it and then somebody's project
managing the whole process collecting
the results analyzing the results and
then obviously your business leaders
will be making a decision again
timelines you can typically do one use
case within a month often it can be
faster than that although it depends on
how complex the solution is typically
you break this down into one segment
that's about defining your criteria
recruiting your team and agreeing on
what you're testing a second segment
which is figuring out how you're going
to test this is generally some point
testing and some trial and error and
some research and then ultimately you
perform your tests you collect your data
and you analyze the results and you make
a decision if you put more people
against this you can get more use cases
test it out in the same time line if
it's a really sophisticated solution it
may take you a little bit longer but
hopefully this gives you a sense of how
to tackle the evaluation of GCS as an
appropriate technology for your use
cases and that's it for this session
thanks so much for joining us I hope you
learn something and that you enjoyed it
we'll be sending you a follow-up email
that has a link to a code lab where you
can get your hands dirty and try GCSE
out for yourself
we'd love your feedback so make sure to
provide that on screen and stay tuned
for our next session